danielle is with us in indianapolis hi
danielle how are you
hi mr anthony and mr hogan how are you
guys great how can we help
good um so my fiance and i have been
listening to your show
for a month or two now and we'd like
your advice on a student loan repayment
decision
um so we're getting married this may
after i graduate from college
and congratulations graduating debt free
thank you
so i'll be graduating debt free is i've
already paid off around eight thousand
dollars
in federal student loans from fellowship
funds that i've been awarded
um during the past two years and my
fiance will graduate college of later in
december of this year
and has around nine thousand dollars of
federal unsubsidized student loan debt
and about ten thousand of private debt
owed to his parents
i would like to pay off his federal
student loan debt now so that it
wouldn't accrue any more interest
before he graduates and to just get it
off of our shoulders as we prepare for
marriage
um but he wants to wait until after he
graduates in december to pay the loan um
so what do you guys think that we should
do
danielle davis twitching over here uh i
felt that i've been around here for 15
years
i i love that you have been intentional
and that you're going to graduate
debt-free this is just
impressive uh did you pay for it or did
your parents pay for it
i paid for it um i'm i've received a
fellowship
like end of five thousand dollars for
the past two years so that has helped me
to pay for it well i'm proud of you
and i would say this and i'm dave's
gonna dive all over this
love that you've joined and you're
listening to this love that you guys
at a young age are talking about this
but i'm going to tell you something
you know first and foremost i wouldn't
be doing anything for his debt until you
guys
are actually married uh until he says i
do
and you do and we do then you can start
to have a plan together
but prior to that you need to stay
focused on what it is you're doing
he needs to come up with a plan to try
to attack that before you get married
yeah after marriage we can do a lot of
stuff
okay so i mean say that we wait until
we get married in may um yeah well you
do that either way but you said in may
then do you pay it off or do you wait
till december
it doesn't matter uh if you've got the
money that's fine after marriage to
knock it out the primary concern of god
is
that he finishes with no additional debt
it'd be a shame to pay it off
and then not have the cash for him to
finish that last semester
in the fall yep so if you've got that
set up and you guys want to go ahead and
start attacking it there's not a wrong
answer you're
both of these are smart choices it's a
smart or be smart
so but all of it comes after may
this is the dave ramsey show